[Musique]
les 5 et 19 mai dernier deux millions et
demi de filles et de garçons âgés de 18
à 21 ans n'ont pas pu voter
pourtant les candidats à l'élection
présidentielle était d'accord pour
avancer l'âge de vote à 18 ou 19 ans
alors certains se demandent pourquoi
avoir attendu aussi longtemps pour
admettre cette maturité intellectuelle
des jeunes constaté par les éducateurs
principal argument des adversaires ne
pas augmenter les barreaux déjà complexe
de l'échelle des différentes majorités
premier barreau 15 ans les filles
peuvent se marier
les lycéens ou les étudiants prendre des
responsabilités dans les établissements
deuxième barreau 16 ans les garçons
s'ils peuvent se marier les travailleurs
prendre des responsabilités dans les
entreprises à 18 ans on al'âge de
risquer la peine de mort on peut se
lancer sur les routes et tenir un fusil
à 19 ans ce qu'ils ont accompli leur
service militaire peuvent voter
enfin il fallait jusqu'à maintenant
attendre 21 ans pour accomplir tous les
actes de droits civils et civiques
cette législation datait du premier
empire elle traversa les années malgré
les attaques de la majorité des partis
et des hommes politiques
plus près de nous de juillet 1968 à
janvier 1973
cette composition de loi sont déposées
aucune n'est mise en discussion à
l'assemblée nationale par contre le 21
juin 1973 le sénat par 225 voix contre
49 votes l'abaissement de la majorité à
18 ans aux positions du président
georges pompidou le projet s'enlise sous
les difficultés économiques du moment
malgré tout les jeunes travailleurs ou
les étudiants les militants ou les non
militants continuent à faire du vote à
18 ans un thème essentiel de leurs
revendications
et c'est une part très importante de la
société il s'intéresse énormément à leur
avenir c'est le moment où ils
choisissent la part qu'ils vont prendre
dans la société
ils sont pleins de fougue ils sont plein
flat moi je trouve que cette terrible
dans la politique c'est que les gens
sont blasés que tout est un ensemble de
calcul de choses finalement très
déplaisantes il serait bon que les
jeunes puissent amener un peu de
fraîcheur à la politique avait de
sincérité mettre plein de fougue et
plein de femmes justement c'est ça peut
être dangereux mais c'est toujours
dangereux mais moi je pense que c'est
avec la flamme qu'on arrive à changer
les choses et que les choses doivent de
toute façon changer le vote à 18 ans
enfin accorder une question se pose
va-t-il modifier l'attitude des jeunes
et des adultes vis-à-vis des jeunes ces
mesures change quelque chose
profondément elle montre un changement
d'attitude
le président de la république a mis en
avant son âge
le nouveau premier ministre a rappelé
qu'il était encore étudiant en 1958 et
que c'était une nouvelle génération
politique qui arrive et avec lui au
pouvoir actuellement et l'on donne le
droit de vote aux jeunes à 18 ans tout
cela montre une volonté de réintégrer ou
d'intégrer la jeunesse dans la
communauté nationale volonté qui
contraste avec une certaine attitude de
méfiance
après les événements de 1968 on avait
même pu parler un certain temps d'un
racisme anti-jeune tout cela est très
important
je montre un changement d'attitude qui
vraisemblablement correspond à un
changement d'attitude et de maturité
également chez les jeunes et répond à
une attente et un besoin abaissé l'âge
de la majorité civile c'est aussi
l'envers d'une médaille
les jeunes rendus responsables doivent
accepter une protection juridique
affaibli mais pour l'instant seuls large
de la majorité électorale est abaissé
[Musique]